[Music]
okay everyone I am so thrilled today
because I am joined by the one and only
Noah Joop AKA Peter and The Magician's
elephant which comes out Friday on
Netflix how you doing today Noah
I'm good man how are you
doing good man uh I hope everything's
going good with you it's just awesome to
see that you're doing voice work now
correct me if I'm wrong but is this
actually your first Voice work you've
done
yes yes it is oh that's exciting so what
about this did you like more than let's
say doing live action
um I loved the process of it
um because you know when you do a live
action movie and you go intensively for
like one month two months and shoot
every day and you're just completely
enveloped by it whereas with this you
know there's there's such a huge process
and it takes so long to animate you know
there's different stages that you have
to go through and you know you'll you'll
do a session and then you'll wait a
couple of months and it really lets you
sit with it and sit with the character
and then come back to it and be like oh
you know I can do that differently or I
could work on that and it because it
gives you a perspective to it so it
really lets you grow with the character
a lot more and um yeah I enjoyed that
yeah and I like you mentioned sitting
with the characters so where you also
had this part to this role where it's
also a character from a book so where
for you did you find the exact voice for
Peter like bringing him alive from the
book how did you kind of go about that
or was that something collaborative in
general
I think it was
um very collaborative with with me and
Wendy Rogers the director
um she she was very helpful and she has
such an incredible way of of
articulating you know she has such a
broad kind of overview of
the entire movie and what she needs to
to sort of pick out and
um and and what level she needs so she
was able to you know work with me and
and find a way for Peter to fit into
this world and find a voice for Peter
um which was you know a lot more
difficult than than it it looks you know
I didn't just go in there and kind of
use my normal voice I really kind of you
know you have to physically get get into
it and um yeah it's it it was um it was
great it was a challenge but but it was
really fun no and the voice came out
great and I think book readers are gonna
love how it sounds I think it sounds
like probably Peter to them that was in
their head so that's really cool
um when in this process though
did you find out that the animated Peter
would have a resemblance to you like did
you have say in that how did that kind
of come about
um so interestingly enough when
think it was
before I even like signed on to the
project I am I basically
had a zoom call with Wendy and Julia the
the producer and um they showed me a few
like uh initial animations and Peter
like already looked that way
um and so I think the character like
almost already looked like me before I
even signed on to to play hymns which is
great but I I do know that they had a
little camera
um in all of the recording sessions
recording me my facial expressions
um to kind of give them a sort of Realm
of when they were animating of um so I
do know there's a little bit of me in
there and like oh okay I love to hear
that that's cool because I definitely
feel that that that's crazy though that
it was already kind of looking like you
before even revolved that's that's
pretty wild so you're speaking to of
like the recording sessions where all
these for you solo or did you ever have
any actors with you how did you kind of
do that I think um you know we all would
have loved to to have some you know with
other people and um but I just think you
know with with covid and with
um everyone being across the world and
you know everyone having other jobs to
do it just it's easier to kind of do it
one by one
um but I mean it's it's a challenge
especially for Wendy you know to be able
to see each person and and kind of piece
everyone together and bring everyone to
the same level
um so you know props to her for being
able to to do that yeah and I definitely
feel that for sure like it feels like
you guys are on the same room which is
cool and it's cool to hear that that
wasn't even the case
um is there a challenge or speaking of
challenges but is there a challenge to
reading lines to an elephant at times
like do you have to use your a lot of
your imagination here when you're going
through this scene like what you're
actually seeing or talking to
I yeah one of the reasons I love this
experience was because if the you know
Reawakening of my imagination I mean I
have a very strong imagination I like to
like to say but this really challenged
that you know
it really being stuck in a room with
like you know just a screen in front of
you not not even any images of just a
microphone
um and basically having to talk to an
elephant
um is is pretty it is pretty tough but
you know you do like I you know
completely using my imagination
um and and yeah I think it I think it uh
it grew a lot throughout the uh
throughout the time of recording this my
imagination which is great no that's
yeah absolutely and it's cool that you
like it because I feel like animated
stuff is just hot right now and that
also goes to video games so like do you
see yourself doing more Voice work after
this or even interested in doing video
games
I mean I'm down for like whatever I
really I what this experience taught me
is that you know doing these different
um having these different challenges
having these different experiences means
that like you know now when I go back to
doing a live action movie I'll take all
of the stuff I've learned from the
animation
um and and like you know filter it down
to whatever you need to to do for for
that movie so everything you know
everything and anything
um any project will teach you teach you
something so um yeah not for anything
that's interesting and I like that
answer and also that you're mentioning
live action and learning things I was
wondering too because you've done a lot
of live action and worked with like huge
stars like Nicole Kidman Emily Blunt
have you learned anything from working
with that level of talent that you keep
with you forever now and where you're
going in your career
yeah I mean I I I've learned so much and
I I won't stop learning I mean that you
know the day I stopped learning
something on set is the day I'll quit
I'll quit my job yeah like I'm not
learning and watching people and using
them and using you know their their way
of working to to my advantage and and um
taking notes from them
um yeah as soon as I start like thinking
that I know it all that's that's a bad
sign okay so at that point though too
about like knowing things and learning
things do you feel like no because you
started so young in an early part in
your life do you feel where you are now
you have though like a set Noah process
you feel more comfortable in General on
a set no I have a I have a confidence
now that is the only thing that I have
like I have a a confidence that I can do
a job you know that doesn't mean that I
have the same process to do that job it
just means that I trust myself enough to
like
jump in the deep end and and and like go
crazy with risking things and stuff
um because I've made it out before so
I'm like okay I can make it out again
yeah no that that's a great answer and
yeah I could see the confidence growing
too which is awesome and
um my last question for you before I let
you go is there any animated shows or
movies you watch currently anything
you're into with that or if not
something you were into growing up maybe
my biggest and my biggest animation love
um was is Studio Ghibli oh well yeah
I've watched every single I've watched
every single movie from them
um and it was a huge part of my
childhood and you know that that is the
epitome of animation for me oh that's
great and I would love to see you work
on one of their projects today that'd be
really cool so but for now everyone
watch Noah crush it as Peter and The
Magician's elephant which comes out
Friday on Netflix Noah thank you so much
for joining me today and hope talking in
the future man